Let's talk about something super happy
which is this highly
anticipated Friends reunion.
Ooh yeah.
And then it gets pushed
because of this crisis
we're all going through.
Yeah.
So, I know that that must
have felt a little bit like
oh, we're gonna do this now, but wait, no,
now we're not gonna do it for a while.
Do you know when you're doing it?
We have something on the
books for us to do it.
At some point in August,
and we'll see,
I mean, we're all still
waiting for guidelines
for shooting things, so, hopefully,
yeah, that would be great.
You know what would
really piss people off?
If you guys did it but it was on Zoom.
So the highly anticipated
all of you getting together
was you guys on Zoom.
Still not in the same room.
You're not in the same room
and you can't really hear
each other that well.
And then you say, well, there it is.
Goodbye, America.
(Lisa laughs)
Come on, that'd be a fun prank.
That would be great.
That would be so good.
And then freezing, it's like
I'll never forget the time
you were insane and you.
(Conan laughing)
Yeah.
Remember?
Remember, Jennifer, that
time that you did that thing
we never forgave you for which was
and then you all freeze.
And then you come back
and you're all laughing.
That's fantastic.
I would love that.
Just do that, please.
I'm good at thinking of
ideas that ruin things.
And that's what I think
would be a great prank.
Great prank on America.
Those are the most fun.